today we're going to be getting a
behind-the-scenes look at jimmy fallon
and jimmy kimmel's epic april fool's day
prank where they surprise their
audiences by swapping shows yeah this is
pretty epic uh in a new interview with
the hollywood reporter the host revealed
that jimmy kimmel came up with the idea
four years ago over dinner
man did it ever pay off well bye guys
i'm confused who's more confused
me or you guys i have no idea guillermo
you know who i am right yeah yeah jimmy
yeah jimmy
that's correct
hey good to see you how you doing nice
to see you this is just for you to speak
oh perfect thank you very much
do what say it again jimmy let's stop it
spit into you okay thank you
[Music]
something i do
what have you heard i don't spit
anything
a spittoon was on my rider
is your cup to spit into
welcome back to jimmy kimmel live i am
jimmy fallon let's just start the show
you guys want to start the show
[Music]
our first guest tonight
we're already one spit into it and let's
see how
you are up to
wow
whoa
wow
oh please
oh please really
you see him enough why would you clap
for it oh my god big deal
how's that hole in l.a that way
i've been in la for like four hours and
ernie you are very tan and i am as white
as a sheep
everybody can hear jimmy write well here
in the studio yeah okay great okay
good
all right
[Applause]
[Applause]
i'm fine staying here